[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRIS SMITH: Welcome to .NET
Containers on the Google Cloud
platform.
[AUDIENCE CHEERS]
That's right.
Let's give it up for this talk.
[AUDIENCE CLAPS]
I guess from the title
you know everything
that it's going to be about.
But actually, it's beyond
just containers that are .NET
on Google Cloud Platform.
Together, everyone
in this audience
is going to bring mankind one
step closer to world peace,
because there is a long running
feud, a misunderstanding,
a conflict that together
we are all going to solve.
So to start with--
let me introduce ourselves.
Neither of those guys are us,
but my name is Chris Smith
JOHN SKEET: And I'm John Skeet.
CHRIS SMITH: And
this is our talk.
So let me introduce myself.
My name's Chris.
I'm a staff software
engineer at Google.
In a former life, I
worked at Microsoft
on Visual Studio on the
Managed Languages team.
And this beautiful
book, "Programming F#"
out by O'Reilly--
I mean, I don't want
to brag or nothing,
but it's in its second edition
because it's really good.
JOHN SKEET:
Congratulations, Chris.
Hi.
I'm John Skeet, everyone.
Happy International Women's Day.
I'm also a software
engineer in Google.
I have not previously been a
software engineer at Microsoft,
but I'd like to think I
know a bit or two about C#.
I too, have written a
book, "C# in Depth,"
now in its third edition.
CHRIS SMITH: Oh!
Shots fired, snap!
JOHN SKEET: Hey.
So between us we
know and love .NET.
And we would like to try to find
out in the next 45 minutes just
which of these
languages is better.
You know, I love C# deeply.
Chris likes this
kind of F# language.
So, you know, Chris has a theory
which he would like to expound.
CHRIS SMITH: A theory?
No.
This is a scientific
rigor that I've
been thinking about on how
to evaluate a programming
language.
Because, I mean, we
act like friends,
but really there's a little
bit of conflict here.
And it's because-- how do
you evaluate a programming
language?
Sure.
We could bore you with language
features, and usage statistics,
and the theory that
goes into these.
But there is a much better
metric that's easier to use
and can harness the
power of Google's cloud,
and that is Book Covers.
So here's an example proof.
"Programming F#" and its
fat bird, and "C# in Depth"
and its dude in-- with
a guy playing a banjo.
If F# is to C#, as fat bird is
to guy with banjo, fat birds,
while admittedly
not super awesome,
strictly better than
guys with banjos.
Ergo, F# is better than C#.
Quod erat demonstrandum.
That which was proved.
Boom.
JOHN SKEET: See, he's
trying with the Latin.
I prefer the original Greek.
Hoper edei dexai.
That which precisely was
required to be proved.
Rather better.
So we know this is--
well, I certainly
know-- this isn't
going to be terribly
scientific as a way of
judging programming languages.
But it is a really good way of
demonstrating what we can do
with .NET on containers,
on Google Cloud Platform.
So if you could go to judge a
programming book by its cover,
you will see a, I would say,
fairly terrible web application
that Chris and I have
written between us in .NET.
And you can judge now--
judge now, judge often.
Whenever Chris is talking,
feel free to just go
to the website, judge.
And by the end of the talk,
we will know definitively
which is the better language.
CHRIS SMITH: That
sounds about right.
Now, if you do go and
vote at JudgeAProgrammin
gBookByItsCover.com,
the covers you will see
are a little unique.
Such as crusher foes with
VB.NET, PHP-grade enterprise
security, or my personal
favorite, All the Cool Kids
are Using Go.
JOHN SKEET: So what
you're saying, Chris,
is not only are we providing you
value in terms of running .NET,
but we're also providing
you inspiration for writing
your own book in the future.
CHRIS SMITH: That's right.
As it turns out,
the lawyers were not
happy with us using the
data wonderfully provided
by the Internet
Archives' Open Library
Project, which is a shame.
So we all know,
again, like John said,
that maybe book covers
and judging a programming
language by it isn't
a scientific measure.
But it is a great backdrop in
which to describe how to deploy
.NET applications to containers
and run them on the Google
Cloud Platform.
So here's what the next 45
minutes or so will be about.
First, I'm going to give an
introduction to containers
and what they mean for,
say, a .NET developer.
How we can build
these containerized
apps for the Google
Cloud Platform.
And then go into specifically
the Google App Engine
flexible environment and
Google Container Engine
for running these
containers on the cloud.
And finally, show all
of the wonderful things
that Stackdriver
diagnostics can allow
you to see in terms of
insights in your application.
So let's start with
some wonderful books
you can find on our website.
You know, "What is a Container"
or "Stress-free deployment with
Containers".
The simplest way
to break this down
is-- think of a container
as a way to deploy software.
If you have a lot of experience
with distributed applications,
maybe you used Xcopy, maybe
you build Windows Installers,
maybe you just use two-gigabyte
virtual image disks
and ship those around.
Well, that's kind of a
problem and can be a pain.
It's tedious, error prone.
And if you want to
really talk about scaling
your application,
replicating extra copies,
maybe have one, 10, 1,000
versions of that running
across various
machines, you need
to have a consistent
and reliable mechanism
for packaging up your software.
And that's what a container is.
It's a way to
deploy your software
and describe it in such
a way that it can easily
be moved around and ran
on different machines
without needing to know a
lot about the target machine.
Now, there some
interesting concepts,
such as the OS level
implementation,
or virtualization, or some of
the small isolation or security
benefits.
But for this talk let's
just say that containers
are a mechanism of deployment.
So once you have that container,
what do you do with it?
How do you run it?
If I have a container,
what do I do with it?
And the beauty of containers is
that it doesn't really matter.
How the container gets ran,
how it scales up or down,
shouldn't concern you.
It's just a matter of
you have your software,
it's in a container, and some
other orchestration layer
takes care of running
it on machines.
So if we look at the
Google Cloud Platform,
you can see all
of the options you
have for running containers.
Let's go from left to right,
starting with Google Compute
Engine.
Google Compute Engine is
infrastructure as a service.
You have a VM.
It's close to the bare metal.
You can do whatever
you want with that VM,
and therein lies all the
power and capabilities.
You can define how your
containers are ran,
what orchestration
layer you're using.
It's wonderful.
It does come with
a serious drawback,
however, in that it
gives you all this power,
and you have to decide how
your software is running
and how to orchestrate it.
And so it can be kind of a pain.
But if you go to Google
Container Engine,
the unit of deployment there
isn't just a VM, but rather
how to run a series
of containers
and expose it in a cluster,
organized as internal services
or external services.
You're defining how software--
you give it your containers
and you define how they should
be scaled up or rolled out,
but not necessarily how
they should be scheduled,
which specific VM
should run which
specific container, and so on.
And so some of these
capabilities of load balancing
or rollout are handled by
Google Compute Engine, which
is implemented essentially
as a Google-specific
version of Kubernetes,
an open source container
orchestration software
that you'll probably hear
a lot about at this conference.
And finally, there's
Google App Engine,
which is the traditional
platform as a service.
In the past, App
Engine would give you
a lot of great benefits
such as great API's to use,
automatic scaling, and so on.
The drawback was
that you had to run
your software in
a special sandbox
that App Engine would then use.
And the biggest drawback,
at least for me,
was that you couldn't run
.NET apps on App Engine.
That was, of course, until App
Engine Flexible Environment.
That's a feature of App
Engine that takes a container
and runs that, scales
it up, provides many
of the other benefits of
App Engine, the platform
as a service, but you control
the software that's being ran.
You can specify whatever
VM or software you want.
So today we have launched a .NET
core container that can be ran
on Google Container Engine
or Google App Engine Flexible
Environment, so that you
can take .NET applications,
run them on the .NET
core infrastructure,
and scale them out
on Google's cloud.
So for our talk, we're going
to focus on primarily Container
Engine and App Engine.
So now let's start to look
at how we actually go about
building an application,
a .NET application,
and putting it on
Google's cloud.
Could we switch to the
demo machine, please?
All right, so I'm going
to talk about two tools--
Cloud Tools for Visual Studio,
and Cloud Tools for PowerShell.
Whenever there's a new
technology, or framework,
or something, it's great.
But you've got to learn
all these new tools
and these new idioms, and
it's just a road bump.
And so for Cloud Tools
for Visual Studio
and Cloud Tools for
PowerShell, we're
just trying to provide
extensions for the tools
you already use and love.
So John's going to open up
the Cloud Explore, which
is part of our Visual
Studio extension
that allows you to browse
your cloud platform resources.
We launched this in the
middle of last year,
and then we've just
continually been
adding more and more resource
browsers and visualizers
within our extension.
With the long term
goal of just allowing
you to manage a lot of your
resources from within the IDE
and not needing to switch
between the Google Cloud
console, your development
environment, and so on.
And if you're wondering
where to get it,
you can just go to the
Manage Extensions and Updates
page in Visual Studio, and
just search for Google Cloud.
And important to
note, we are running
with the latest and greatest
version of the extension which
just came out today.
JOHN SKEET: And I
installed it this morning.
CHRIS SMITH: Right.
So if you type
really, really fast,
you can run through the
same demo on your laptop,
in the audience.
Although, I would be very
impressed if you could do so.
So Visual Studio Extensions.
That's great.
But having an IDE
clicking around,
it's not for everyone,
for every task.
And so we also have Cloud
Tools for PowerShell
as a way to use the command
line environment to manipulate
your cloud resources.
For an interactive
sort of session,
you can just use the GCloud
command, and that's fine.
But for things a
little more advanced,
like automating common
tasks, or scripting things,
maybe you don't want to
break down and write a custom
application but just maybe a
100-line PowerShell script.
So John's going to show
us the commands that
are available in the Google
Cloud PowerShell module.
And this is installed with the
Cloud SDK on Windows machines.
So you likely already
have this available.
JOHN SKEET: We will not be
going through every single one
of these.
CHRIS SMITH: Yeah.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHS]
We have more than 10.
JOHN SKEET: We'll just
say there's a lot.
CHRIS SMITH: Now,
for our application,
JudgeAProgrammin
gBookByItsCover.com,
we are storing the book covers
on Google Cloud Storage.
So let's see what buckets we
have on Google Cloud Storage.
We can use the
Get-GcsBucket command.
And Cloud Storage
is going to return
the strongly-typed
bucket objects.
These aren't just
string representations,
these are objects that have
time stamps, names, other pieces
of metadata.
And so you can see
in addition to where
we're hosting, say, the
containers and other pieces
of data, the
prog-book-covers Bucket,
where all the data is stored.
Now, we can continue to use
these commandlets as objects
or whatnot, but
conceptually, I think
of cloud storage as a really,
really, really, big hard drive.
And one of the
benefits of PowerShell
is you can create providers to
treat non-file system resources
as file systems or something.
Why don't you just show it off?
JOHN SKEET: So all we
need to do is just change
directory to prog-book-covers.
And we can just see what's
in there as if we were just
browsing a local hard disk,
and then we could look in, say,
covers, and then look
in covers//large.
CHRIS SMITH: And use the
common basic PowerShell
commands, and it'll behave as
if it is a local file system.
Which, to be clear, it is not.
Not everything is supported
in the PowerShell provider.
But if you're just trying to
navigate or browse some data,
it's much more
productive than, say,
using these other
standard commandlets.
But just so we don't spend
too much time on PowerShell,
we'll show off one
more commandlet,
which is how to
pipeline these results.
So by composing different
PowerShell commandlets,
we can do some advanced
transformer query--
JOHN SKEET: Can I stop
typing while you--
CHRIS SMITH: Oh, yes, yes.
John has a--
JOHN SKEET: It's quite long.
CHRIS SMITH: --cheat sheet.
What we want to do is
see all of the best book
covers that we have.
And, of course,
that means we need
to get all of the book covers
from the programming book
covers bucket.
Those that are in
the generated folder,
get their name, metadata size.
And then filter them such that
the metadata's language value
is equal to F#.
And then output
it to a grid view.
JOHN SKEET: Oh, there
weren't any called just C#.
So you've changed it for F#.
CHRIS SMITH: You know--
JOHN SKEET: Oh, no.
I found nothing.
I'll tell you what.
If we can't find
anything, let's just
get rid of the where clause.
Exactly as you would-- right.
So there's plenty in there.
CHRIS SMITH: Oh.
NE-- or EQ.
Yes.
PowerShell semantics, yo.
JOHN SKEET: Yo, I'm not
a PowerShell developer.
So now we see all the C# books.
CHRIS SMITH: And this is all
just standard PowerShell.
You can use these today.
It's all great.
OK.
Enough about the tools, let's
start talking about the code.
And for that I will have John
demo a wonderful application
written in a very
unwonderful language, C#.
[JOHN CHUCKLES]
JOHN SKEET: OK.
So Chris has been
talking for a while,
so I hope you've had
lots of time to vote.
I'll just describe the
application just a little bit
to start with.
So we've got a back-end that
is responsible for storing all
the votes, returning
lists of books,
or a random book, et cetera.
It just returns stuff with
web API, returning it in JSON.
And we've got a front-end, all
this written in ASP.NET Core,
with Razor Views, et
cetera, entirely as
normal talking to the
back-end using HttpClient.
And we've got some storage
that is sort of away
from the application itself.
Does any of that, so
far, sound like something
that would be specifically
at a Google Cloud conference?
No.
It's entirely what
you could have
written at home before
even hearing about Google.
It so happens that the
application that we've got
uses Google Cloud
Datastore as its storage.
And we've got some
little neat tricks
using Stackdriver to
make it much easier
to manage within the cloud.
But I do want to
keep emphasizing
that this is just ASP.NET Core.
So all the learning
you've already completed,
and there's been a lot to
learn recently, let's face it,
around what's new in
ASP.NET Core, all of that
applies immediately to
everything we're talking about.
So we've got this
simple application.
If I go back to
Solution Explorer,
you can tell I'm
really old school.
I prefer the Visual
Studio 6 style
of having Solution Explorer
on the left instead
of on the right.
So we've got five projects here.
The important ones being
back-end, web, and models.
And I'll just start
that going because it
takes a little bit of time
to just ramp up the debugger.
So this is now just
running locally.
We can still talk
to Cloud Datastore
from our local machine.
And if I go to--
this is the back-end,
so this is automatically
going to the languages' URL.
And this is just going
to show us in JSON,
using JSON.NET, the data that
comes back from the back-end.
And I can ask for
a random C# book,
and it will give us all
the relevant information.
I could ask to see
the votes, et cetera.
Then this is the front-end,
and this is all just
running locally.
So this is all fine.
And none of this should
be at all surprising.
I sometimes try to impress
in talks, none of this
is impressive yet.
So we have an ASP.NET
Core application.
OK?
What comes next, Chris?
CHRIS SMITH: Where's the
Google App Engine Flexible
Environment-specific goo?
JOHN SKEET: I'm
so glad you asked.
Well, we could deploy this to
App Engine Flexible Environment
without having mentioned
Google at all in the code.
So literally-- and the
way I initially tested
the application when
my colleague Ivan said,
hey, we've got to build the
Visual Studio extension.
Why don't you give it a try?
I said, new project--
ASP.NET Core application.
OK.
I will run it locally.
Yes.
It says, hello, welcome
to ASP.NET Core.
Deploy to App Engine.
And none of that needed any
Google stuff at all other
than the Visual
Studio extension.
But let me just right
click on a project.
I'll stop debugging.
It will detect that it's an
ASP.NET Core application.
And so enable this--
Publish to Google Cloud.
I hope that's readable
enough to you.
And when you click on
Publish to Google Cloud,
you get the choice of App
Engine Flex or Container Engine.
When you pick App Engine
Flex, all you need to specify
is a version name that's
automatically filled
in for you, whether or not
to promote it, which means
start directing all
the traffic towards it.
So if this were
some kind of Canary
build that you weren't
entirely sure about, you want
to send 1% of traffic
to it to start with,
you just not promote
it within the IDE here.
And you can later
on sort of choose
how to do your traffic split
within the Google Cloud
console.
And then we can open the
site after publishing.
So I'm not going to do that.
But I will point out
a couple of things.
We have two services, App
Engine really helpfully gives us
DNS entries automatically.
So we will have ProgrammingBooks
ByCovers.appspot.com.
But we've got two services.
One of them needs
to be the back-end.
That's got to be hosted
on a different IP address.
So how would you do that?
Are any of you App Engine
developers already?
At the back-- right.
What file would you look at
if you wanted to customize
your App Engine application?
App.yaml, was that--
I hope you said app.yaml.
I couldn't hear
entirely clearly.
CHRIS SMITH: That
was the right answer.
JOHN SKEET: It was
the right answer.
So here, again, we
have an app.yaml.
And in this case we're
specifying that the runtime
is ASP.NET Core.
We didn't have to-- if you
just created your ASP.NET Core
completely default
project and deployed,
you don't need to
create this file.
The extension will create
it explicitly for you
if you ask it to.
There's another
context menu item
to say generate me an
app.yaml and a Dockerfile.
But if you don't need
any customization at all,
it can just go and generate that
in the background, somewhere
hidden, and then deploy
things, and then it's gone.
But if you do need
to customize it,
all you need is to
specify these two things.
And then service back-end just
says, we want this back-end.
We want this service
to be called back-end.
And we can see this is
actually deployed if we go
to backend.programm
ingbooksbycover.
appspot.com/languages, then we
can see exactly the same thing.
So that is now code that is
running on App Engine Flexible
Environment.
CHRIS SMITH: And this
is one of the benefits
of App Engine is
that it provides you
the DNS automatically.
I mean, you probably don't
want to have your entire
company's website have
a .appspot.com address.
JOHN SKEET: But for a
Friday afternoon experiment,
it's really handy.
CHRIS SMITH: It's much more
convenient than remembering
the IP address of some VM
and some Kubernetes cluster
and so on.
JOHN SKEET: And in order
to get going with this, all
you would have to do--
I think you would possibly
have to go into Cloud Console
and enable App Engine,
but that's kind of it.
You don't need to
set up a cluster.
Whereas for Container Engine,
which we'll come onto later on,
you do need to go through a
step of setting up your cluster.
Which has the benefits of
allowing you to size it,
and say where it is,
and all kinds of things
that when you want more control,
Google can give it to you.
When you just say,
just deploy the stuff,
you can do that, too.
OK.
So that's running on App Engine.
We can make exactly the same
code run on Container Engine,
as well.
And it's the Container Engine
version that JudgeAProgrammin
gBookByItsCover.com-- could you
not have chosen some shorter
name for this?
CHRIS SMITH: No.
JOHN SKEET: That site is
hooked up to Container Engine.
And we can prove that now.
So if we go to JudgeAProgrammin
gBookByItsCover.com.
And we'll just see,
I didn't actually
show you the details of the
app, which is all of this page.
And we've got a stats page
showing how many-- hey,
they've been voting.
It's great.
You must have been
speaking for quite a while.
It's good.
So we can see that
there's the covers.
And we can see there's
a bit of a mistake
in this site at the moment.
You see here it says, "Code
by Chris Smith and Jon Skeet".
OK, so that's clearly
the wrong way around.
So we're just going to fix
that and deploy straight
to Container Engine.
So all I need to do
is find the layout.
So this would be common
across all pages.
And here we go.
Here's the "Code by--".
Let's give it a bit
of emphasis as well.
OK.
So we're happy.
We would obviously
normally test it locally.
But we can just hit--
I haven't even hit
Build, because I
know that doing Publish will
do a build automatically.
I don't need to rely
on the compiler.
I'll just see whether
it publishes properly.
So Container Engine from
the same menu as before.
And this time we have a few more
things that we can configure.
And that's partly
because right now this
is all you can configure when
publishing from Container
Engine, from Visual Studio.
So we don't have the
equivalent of app.yaml
for extra configuration, things
like environment variables
and whatever.
I would hasten to add that this
is in the current iteration.
We definitely want to
expand the range of services
and the depth of the
experience in each case.
And we would very,
very much welcome
feedback as to how
you would particularly
want to see that happen
and which aspects you
want to customize.
So I'm going to
call it front-end,
because I know that that's what
my deployment name is called.
And here we can choose whether
or not to expose a service.
So in Kubernetes, a service is
a set of replicated containers
that all look like
one thing to, not
necessarily the outside
world, but to everything else.
So my back-end is a
service that is not
exposed to the public
internet, unlike we
saw on appspot.com for the
back-end on App Engine Flex.
Nothing can get to our
back-end on Container Engine,
apart from other things
within the cluster.
So for the back-end, I do
still have Exposer service,
but I don't take the make-up
service public because I'm
deploying the front-end now.
We can just hit Publish.
Having said, we do
want to make it public.
CHRIS SMITH: And
worth pointing out--
this is using an
existing cluster
that's been set up on
Google Container Engine.
This is something
that I don't believe
we have the support for just
yet in creating new clusters.
JOHN SKEET: Not
within Visual Studio.
But it's pretty easy.
If you know how to use a
web browser, you can do it.
So while this is deploying--
and we can see what it's doing.
So it's currently going through
all the dotnet publish aspect.
So, again, when I
was emphasizing--
you may get sick of
me emphasizing this--
this is just regular
ASP.NET Core.
The whole aim is
for you not to have
to learn a load of new things.
So if it works with
dotnet publish,
if you've got some
extra bit of tooling
in your currently project JSON,
but obviously in Visual Studio
2017, you'll see
as proj, et cetera.
We're just saying,
hey, ASP.NET Core,
could you publish the
application, please?
And then we're taking
those published bits.
We're then sending them up
to a cloud container builder.
So I don't have anything
on my local machine
that can build a
container image.
But that's fine because Google
has got our back covered.
We can do all of
that in the cloud.
So that's all happening in
the background at the moment.
And I said that we don't have
much support for configuring
really customized bits when
you're deploying to Container
Engine in Visual Studio.
But it really is just
using Kubernetes.
Just as we're just
using ASP.NET Core,
we're just using Kubernetes
as it's meant to be used.
So if you already have
Kubernetes set up,
and you've got some Ruby,
you've got some PHP,
you've got some Go,
some Python, we're just
going to fit in there.
You can just deploy
a new service,
and your other services
will be able to talk to it.
They'll be able to talk
the other way around.
And if you want to deploy
using Kubectl, which
is the sort of common
tool for Kubernetes,
that's absolutely fine, too.
You can do the same thing
that Visual Studio is doing.
We're not trying
to do anything--
it's much easier for us if
we don't have to be clever.
If we can just use all the
smarts that everyone else,
whether it's from Microsoft
with ASP.NET Core,
or our partners and colleagues
in the Kubernetes and Container
Engine team.
If we can use
everything they've done,
why would we want to
build it ourselves?
CHRIS SMITH: Show me that
slick Kubernetes URI.
JOHN SKEET: So we can run--
anyone who is using
Kubernetes already
will know about running
Kubectl proxy, which
runs its own local web server.
So you can see what your
application is doing.
So we can see that we've
got two deployments.
If we look at the pods--
I'm not going to go into all
the details of what pods mean.
But, oh, this one's been up.
The front-end, our
three pods, because it's
replicated three times, have
been up for about 20 seconds.
So it looks like
we've padded enough
to do all the deployment stuff.
CHRIS SMITH: Huzzah!
JOHN SKEET: So we can prove that
that's the case by going back
to the website.
And let's see whether the
correction that we've made
works.
Yep.
We can see that now it's in
a much more sensible order.
Let's just check that the
stats page is still working.
CHRIS SMITH: And--
JOHN SKEET: Hang on.
The stats page is taking
a bit longer than normal.
OK.
CHRIS SMITH: But there's
a lot of good votes.
JOHN SKEET: Yeah.
But we just need to
hold on for a minute.
I'm always a bit
distressed when a talk
starts going a bit wrong.
So I'm just going to
have a look and see
in the cloud
console what's going
on when we hit that Votes page.
That shouldn't take that long.
So we're just going to look
into Stackdriver trace.
I mentioned
Stackdriver earlier on.
And I can just look at
what's been going on.
Let's just look last hour
and then zoom in over here.
CHRIS SMITH: So the
Stackdriver Trace feature
allows you to have
insights into what's
happening behind the scenes
in your applications.
For example, making
requests to other services,
reading and writing
from databases.
JOHN SKEET: So, for example--
hang on Chris, hang on.
So, for example,
this is a request
to our stats page
on our front-end.
And Chris was just
trying to flannel there,
so that you couldn't see what
was going on in this request.
Look at this.
So this is requests from our
front-end to our back-end.
I know-- because I wrote
most of this code--
I know that when we hit
the stats page it should
ask the back-end, show
me the number of votes
for each language, and then it
can do a bit of aggregation.
It should not be fetching
a random F# book,
a random C# book, and
then casting a vote--
and doing it 10 times
by the looks of it.
OK.
At this point--
CHRIS SMITH: I don't know
what you're talking about.
JOHN SKEET: Well, at this
point, the code cannot lie.
We've just deployed the
code from this very laptop.
CHRIS SMITH: I don't know who
has access to that laptop.
JOHN SKEET: Yeah.
I remember when I
went to the restroom,
and you seemed to
be hovering around.
Let's have a look.
So we know it's the
book's controller.
Is this in the front-end?
Yeah.
OK.
So let's have a
look at the stats.
OK.
I'm so disappointed.
Do you know what
disappoints me most?
It's not the blatant cheating.
CHRIS SMITH: Cheating?
I'm simply--
JOHN SKEET: Look at this.
Look at this.
We have two operations that
are asynchronous operations.
And Chris is waiting
for the first one
to finish before he
makes the second one.
At least cheat properly, Chris.
Look, look.
I'll correct the cheating.
Task equals this.
And then we can do the
same for the C# one.
And then we can at least
do things properly.
See, you can tell he's not
used to a decent language.
There we go.
CHRIS SMITH: If only C# had
proper support for Monads
and computation expressions,
instead of this clunky async--
JOHN SKEET: Right.
Yeah, because that
was so clunky,
adding two lines just to-- ah!
Anyway.
The point is it was
really easy to see
what was happening in that
specific front-end call.
CHRIS SMITH: So, John, sure.
I may or may not have
tried to cheat here, OK?
Tell me what sort of
nefarious contortions
you had to do to the code
so that you enabled Trace.
JOHN SKEET: OK.
So, firstly, most
importantly, we
had to start by installing
the NuGet packages.
Obviously, the way that you get
packages in .NET is with NuGet.
So they're all NuGet.org.
And if we look at
our project .JSON,
we'll see we've got
a bunch of packages.
And in fact, for a couple
of reasons I won't go into,
there are a few more packages
here than you would normally
see, or you'd
normally need to see,
is the data store one and
the Google Cloud diagnostics
ASP.NET Core.
So these aren't yet in beta
even, but we're getting there.
So once you've
installed the packages,
then in your start
up, because that's
where you configure
things in ASP.NET Core,
all we need to do in
configure services
is we just say we're
going to add Google Trace.
And in fact, normally--
I added a little
bit of a crutch just
in case there was
so much traffic
that we happen not to capture
the stats requests that I made.
You can override things
to explicitly say,
I really want to
trace this call,
rather than just relying on a 1
QPS sort of statistical aspect.
But if you're happy
with defaults,
it's as simple as
just saying, just
add Google Trace
for this project.
And at the same time in
the Configure method,
I'm saying, yep, I want
to use Google Logging.
And there are other
options you can give.
That's logging informational
things at the moment.
And I also want to use
Google Exception Logging.
So that's enough to get
started for some tracing.
But there are two
extra bits that I
needed to do in order
to see this hooking up
from the front-end
to the back-end.
And that's really, I
think, where the power is.
So we're using HttpClient
to make this request.
And HttpClient is
built so that you
can hook in your own listeners,
and it's very, very simple.
In my JSON back-end, which is
very simple code, all we do
is we create an HttpClient
from a Trace Header Propagating
Handler, which is a
scary name for what you
want to put into an HttpClient.
And that gets just injected
by dependency injection
as is entirely idiomatic
for ASP.NET Core.
Have you spotted some
kind of pattern here?
We want to be very much
doing the right thing
for the platform that
we're working with.
So you create an HttpClient.
And then when the
front-end says,
OK, I'm going to create a trace
with an ID of blah blah blah.
Then when you make any HTTP
request with that HttpClient,
it's automatically going to add
a header that the equivalent
code down in the
back-end is going
to say, ah, I see you've
already got that Trace Header.
So therefore I will
make sure that when
I do any tracing to say
that I've got the request,
or any manual tracing
that you're doing,
it all attaches it together.
Which means you can
see what's going on.
CHRIS SMITH: Sounds like it's a
really complicated way to say,
it just works like you want.
JOHN SKEET: It
just works like you
want with very small bits
that are well-documented
in our samples and things.
The other aspect, as well as
hooking front-end to back-end,
we're also talking to Datastore.
And that hooking isn't
currently done automatically.
So when I have a
Datastore vote repository,
I take an IManaged Tracer.
And this is all
slightly influxed.
We're really trying to make
things as easy as we possibly
can.
But all we need say is, oh,
just run this action here.
So inserting a vote
into Datastore,
just run that in a Trace span
called DatastoreInsertVote.
And, for example,
when we have the--
doing the votes, we need to
do two different Datastore
operations.
We look up a summary of
things until recently,
and then we do a separate query.
So we call RunInSpan again.
And if I go back to
our cheating Trace,
I'll see right at the bottom--
oh, no, I think I
ran out of space.
But I think if I look
for stats and try
to find it from back
when it wasn't cheating--
is that a Stats one?
I'm not sure why it's
not filtering to stats.
OK.
There we go.
So back when it wasn't cheating,
so it was a lot quicker.
We can see that we
have DataStoreSummary,
and we know that that
took 14 milliseconds
and DataStoreQueryVotes.
And these happen to be
doing Datastore things.
But the point is that it's only
because I called RunInSpan.
You could be doing
whatever you want.
You could be talking to
completely different services
not even on Google, or doing
your own internal computation,
or calling your
InServices, whatever it is.
These can nest.
It's all beautiful to see what's
going on within your requests.
So that's one aspect of
Stackdriver Diagnostics.
But I've already
sort of shown you
the code to do two
other things, which
is Error Reporting and Logging.
I will briefly show you.
People generally know
what Logging looks like.
So I probably won't
go into that other
than to say it's probably richer
Logging than you're used to.
This is because Google
has a lot of experience
of, you don't want to be looking
through 100 different log
files for one particular
thing just because you've
got two replicated
services, each
with 50 different replicas.
In general, Google
Cloud Platform
tries to build on the
experience that Google's got
of-- we know how
to build software,
and we know the problems
of building software.
So I think you'll
find the Logging
richer than you may be used to.
But the Error Reporting--
obviously, my code normally
doesn't throw any exceptions,
but Chris's code sometimes does.
So I've had to explicitly
add some breaking things
into our application.
So we do have two extra URLs
that you may not be expecting.
One of GoBang that throws
an exception directly.
And the other one
is GoBangBackend,
that makes a request
to the back-end,
and that has another
control that will GoBang.
So let's just visit
both of those URLs.
So if we go to
GoBang, you'll see
I've got the entirely vanilla
ASP.NET Core error page.
Let's hit it a few
times to prove--
CHRIS SMITH: Now, I'd like to
point out that that code is
by John Skeet, first author.
[JOHN LAUGHS]
JOHN SKEET: And we
can do GoBangBackend.
And this time it's not
actually a failure response,
HTTP response from
the front-end,
because we expected it to fail.
But now that we've
had those happen,
and we can make them
happen a few times,
we can go to Stackdriver
Error Reporting.
And we can see not just those,
but everything else that's
happened.
So we can see, OK, we've
got this back-end failure,
and we can see that it's
happened a few times recently.
And once when we were
demoing this in prep earlier,
and once yesterday
when we were prepping.
We've got the Bangety
Bang Bang Bang,
which is the front-end one.
We've got
KeyNotFoundException, which
is Chris Smith not knowing the
proper use of Get-hashcode.
[CHRIS LAUGHS]
I kid you not, and I'm happy
to give more details later
on in private.
But we can see it all.
We have the Stack
Trace right there.
So you can find out what is
going on in your application
very easily, and
that really was--
tracing, we had to add
a few different things.
For Error Reporting,
it really was as simple
as use Google Exception Logging.
The only thing I
would say is you
need to make sure you put
it in the right place.
Previously, I had it
there, at which point
it did entirely different
things because of the way
that the middleware
of ASP.NET Core works.
So if you run into problems
with Error Reporting,
make sure that your code looks
exactly like our sample code.
Well, that's the only little
detail I'll give in that.
CHRIS SMITH: And we should--
JOHN SKEET: But it's easy.
Well, that's the way
that middleware works.
So the Use Exception Handler
there is going to say,
well, I'll just
render the Razor View,
and there's no
longer an exception.
So if we get pulled
after that, we
haven't got anything to report.
CHRIS SMITH: Fair enough.
JOHN SKEET: It's fine.
So with Stackdriver Logging,
Stackdriver Error Reporting,
and Stackdriver Tracing, there's
one aspect to Stackdriver
that I haven't even
mentioned before,
and that's forensic debugging.
I don't have anything to show
you on that front just yet.
But maybe watch this space.
CHRIS SMITH: Boom.
Could we cut back to
the slides, please?
OK.
So we did the super-slick
demo, awe-inspiring demo,
death-defying demo,
mind-blowing demo.
OK, great, no more demos.
Tear.
So we covered quite a few
products, many tools, and so
let's just recap what
we've covered today.
First, we showed Cloud Tools for
Visual Studio and Cloud Tools
for PowerShell as extensions to
the tools that you're probably
using today to build
.NET applications.
And these are just ways
to help make it easier
to transition your
applications to Google's cloud.
Then we covered containers.
Today we launched the ASP.NET
Core container image that you
can then use as a base image
to run .NET applications
on Google's Cloud Platform,
such as App Engine Flexible
Environment, or Google
Container Engine.
And both of those can
be deployment targets
from within Visual Studio.
And then, finally, we
showed off some of the,
dare I say, sweet, sweet
runtime diagnostics that you
can get from Stackdriver.
This is all available from
just adding a reference
to an instrumentation
library and just hooking it
into your application.
You don't need to do a lot of
contorting of your application
to take advantage of this.
Rather, we want to make
it as simple as possible.
All right.
So with that in mind, let
us find out the world's best
programming language.
John, if you could go
to JudgeAProgrammin
gBookByItsCover.com/Winner.
JOHN SKEET: Ah.
If we could switch back to
the demo machine, please?
CHRIS SMITH: And F# sharp
wins by like a bazillion!
Oh, negative 5 votes, John.
Tough break.
OK.
So obviously this is made up.
I just didn't want anyone
to feel bad, right?
Particularly if the
newspaper headline was,
"Google declarers random
programming language
the best in the world."
I want you go to--
JOHN SKEET: Let's
see, winning stats.
So these are with the
actual votes cast.
CHRIS SMITH: And
with some alleged--
JOHN SKEET: Oh,
yeah, with a few--
yeah.
So in fact, every
time that someone's
gone to the stats page.
So we can probably ignore
160 of those votes.
[CHRIS LAUGHS]
And with Logging, we could
easily find out how many times
people have gone to /stats since
we deployed and then just null
out those votes.
CHRIS SMITH: Yeah,
but, you know--
JOHN SKEET: In
fact, look at this.
161 votes for F# and 165.
There's an interesting
balance there, I think.
CHRIS SMITH: Interesting.
Well, we will continue to
argue about this probably
for the rest of our lives.
JOHN SKEET: Oh, we will.
CHRIS SMITH: And so
unfortunately, maybe we
didn't inch mankind
closer to world peace.
I'm sorry.
But at least now we know
how we could potentially
use the Google Cloud Platform to
achieve such a wonderful goal.
Could you go back to
the slides, please?
OK.
So there's many other things
going on in the Windows .NET
Tooling space.
First, there are
plenty of resources,
such as code labs to kind of
get some hands-on experience
with the tools and technologies.
Also the specific landing
page for a .NET or Windows.
There's an upcoming
talk on Windows tomorrow
and about how Windows containers
can be exposed, I believe,
from Server 2016
on Compute Engine.
And then also there's the
meet-the-experts for .NET
tomorrow, from 1:00 to 4:00.
With that I believe we have a
few more minutes for questions.
JOHN SKEET: Just
before questions, I
would like a personal request.
One of the things that we were
talking about before resources
was the libraries.
I'm personally responsible
for the client libraries
that I used for
Datastore, for example.
So if you've used any
Google APIs in the past,
or even if you haven't,
but certainly if you have,
and if you found them
a bit tricky to use,
and sort of seeming to make me
lie about being idiomatic with
exactly fitting into
the C# ways of things,
please give the new ones a try.
And I would love
feedback about it.
They're not GA just
yet, which means
if there's something
that needs changing,
we can still change it.
So please try them
and give me feedback.
[MUSIC PLAYING]